pues en la realidad es que el partido el
líder del partido republicano es el
presidente son el presidente de trump
tiene una aceptación en el partido
republicano que es extraordinaria y el
carisma es impresionante la realidad es
que el presidente de trump está
preocupado por las alegaciones por
ejemplo el estado de aversión a que su
reportaje no mencionó estaban los
oficiales estaban proveyendo
plumas que eran de markers y no plumas
de negra para que las computadoras
pudieran contar a aquellos votantes a
favor en los 300 que votan a favor del
presidente de trump es algo bien
preocupante y tampoco en el estado de
pensilvania los abogados del presidente
de trump y los partidistas republicanos
no pudieron observar el proceso del
conteo en la junta de donde estaban
contando los votos electorales
estos tipos de alegaciones son
extremadamente preocupantes y la
realidad es que hasta que todas estas
preocupaciones sean dirigidas no creo
que habrá paz en los eeuu porque el
pueblo americano está preocupado de que
el voto de ellos si votaron a favor del
presidente eso no será contado señor
esta opinión precisamente el desempeño
de trump en el sur de florida redujo la
ventaja demócrata tradicional en el
condado de miami dade por ejemplo en
texas trump también ganó decenas de
miles de seguidores en comunidades
predominantemente latinas a qué cree que
se debe el mejor desempeño electoral de
este año de trump con los latinos
los latinos están agradecidos porque el
presidente del trump antes de 2019 tenía
una de las economías mejores de la
historia
de la reciente historia de los eeuu
había trabajo para los latinos los
afroamericanos los asiáticos mujeres
etcétera con sueldos que estaban
subiendo antes de la pandemia del cob y
19 así que los latinos a través de los
eeuu tuvieron un apoyo
significante del presidente de trump que
antes se hubiese ido a los demócratas
así como los afroamericanos también muy
bien arte estopiñán muchas gracias por
esta comunicación él es analista
político republicano en washington de la
capital estadounidense